[Musique]
bonsoir tout le monde j'ai très heureux
d'être ici avec vous et d'être là tlx et
de vivre cette expérience ensemble
donc je suis artiste autodidacte
bruxellois je suis ici du graffiti donc
je fais beaucoup de peinture dans
l'espace public
avant c'était de manière illégale mais
non c'est plus des contrats des
commandes
donc voilà ça fait 20 ans que j'ai
commencé la peinture ici je vous
expliquais une expérience que que j'ai
avec un matériel qui est large il
et puis aussi vous parler un peu de
voilà d'actualité ou de mon trajet de
vie et de toutes ces expériences m'ont
trahi en général on me m'identifie
autour de mes écritures qui sont qui ont
un système assez spécifiques qui sont
influencés par plein d'écriture
différentes les rues de mystérieuses les
écriture cunéiforme le tag d'épicés sao
il ya plein plein de richesses est
dedans et
et donc voilà grâce à mon boulot car je
veux travailler partout je voyage pas
mal quand même dans des pays très
diverse très divers j'expose ans des
musées je fais beaucoup de
collaborations avec des artistes et les
voilà je suis un travail très spontané
et je vais vous montrer un peu des
photos expliquer tout ça donc mon épouse
est l'équatorienne j'ai eu deux enfants
avec elle ses parents un terrain en
équateur et là on s'est dit on va partir
un an et on va construire une maison en
bois et vivre un peu en autarcie touché
un peu à la permaculture faire planter
des déserts construire une cabane pour
les enfants ouais on avait notre potager
il va l'être tout quand qui passaient
des colibris et je me suis dit qu'est ce
que je peux faire ici avec mon mari
compagnie donc je me suis dit je vais
m'intéresser à la nature aux écorces
à tous ces matériaux un peu éphémère
qu'on peut trouver partout le calcaire
la terre et du coup j'ai peint sur des
arbres avec du blanc de meudon
donc c'est de la poudre de calcaire que
j'ai ramené d'europe et là j'ai commencé
à peindre des arbres là j'ai trouvé que
cet arbre là n'était pas loin la
propriété et je trouvais les racines
fabuleuse et le support qui est assez
plat qui fait un peu murales et j'ai
voulu vraiment mettre les racines à
l'honneur juste part des lignes très
simple donc ça c'est il ya juste mon
beau père qui est décédé qui a vu cette
fresque sinon ça a été très diffusé sur
le net et mais voilà ça c'est un autre
arbre j'ai écrit des lettres en latin
avec plein d'influencés des kroll des
fioritures et tous avaient ensuite je
masque l'écriture de manière j'ai écrit
de manière très fine si je mets des
traits plus épais et donc vraiment je
masque écriture et les gens doivent
décrypter chercher et là je laisse une
liberté d'interprétation un agent qui
voit des petits personnages ou plein de
choses comme ça
il ya aussi du cacao dans la propriété
alors après le blanc de meudon
à mon retour en belgique j'ai découvert
qu'il ya beaucoup de terre en belgique
et de teintes différentes et donc je
trouve l'argile en poudre
il ya cinq six teintes différentes et là
avec les enfants dans un parc à
bruxelles en parc josaphat qui est
fabuleux parce que ces grands il ya
plein d'armes différents et c'est très
vivant très familial et donc là j'ai
fait participer tous les enfants qui
passaient je laissais des pinceaux de
des petits pots de la peinture et donc
il ya quelque chose d'assez aborigènes
qui se construit là et c'est un grand
succès et c'est chouette et donc les
enfants m'inspire beaucoup
ce qui est une liberté il ya une sauvage
ensuite il ya le musée des égouts amusé
des égouts à bruxelles j'ai même les
bruxellois ils connaissent pas donc
c'est à la porte d'anderlecht près la
gare du midi boulevard poincaré je pense
est donc le musée a fait appel à moi
parce qu'ils ont vu que je travaille
avec des matériaux éphémère écologique
et que actuellement 20 c'est important
de ne pas te renvoyer de produits
chimiques
parce que les peintres avec l'acrylique
les sprays parce que d'esprit j'ai pas
pendant longtemps avec ça et c'est super
mauvais donc c'est pour ça que je me
suis tourné vers ses matériaux donc dans
le musée il ya le collecteur qui est
toujours fonctionnel dont il ya des
montées des eaux dès qu'il ya des dégâts
de la pluie tout ça est donc ça montre
jusqu'aux os rampe que vous voyez est
donc il ya une partie de la peinture qui
part avec l'eau donc là j'ai retranscrit
la parole des égoutiers donc les
égoutiers qui ont qui sont là depuis 30
ans qui travaille dans des conditions
pas possibles qui sont abaissés avec des
petites lampes et des petits rats qui
courent partout et il ya de sacrées
accident et aussi de très belles
histoires et donc j'ai voulu remettre ça
à l'honneur et il y avait un petit
panneau dans dans le musée avec la
retranscription de mon texte comme ça
les gens il devrait aussi chercher des
mots des phrases ou des textes et donc
pendant six mois j'ai travaillé là pas 6
mois à temps plein c'était une fois par
mois
jallet pendant une semaine et
réintroduire un nouveau thème donc la
première c'était récit des des égoutiers
ensuite c'était parler de gaspillage
l'écologie parce qu'on trouve plein
plein de choses en dans les égouts et
les gens beaucoup de personnes jettent
n'importe quoi des cotons tiges de
préservatifs jouets en plastique et
des produits chimiques de l'huile plein
de choses comme ça
ensuite j'ai fait des superpositions
donc c'est comme un palimpseste donc des
choses qui cette phase et moi je viens
réintroduire des nouveaux autres des
nouveaux thèmes nouveaux dessins après
l'écologie tout ça là j'ai introduit la
mythologie grecque avec le styx qui
parce qu'ils passent et on j'ai dessiné
charon sur sa barque avec des mains des
gens qui se nouera en fait et faire un
parallèle avec la migration
j'avais envie de mettre comme ça en
avant c'est que les gens voient là on
voyait un bateau et des ans qui selon
elle les gens faisaient directement
référence à après le le j'ai sauté
quelques tables mais c'est pas très
grave
après le manque d'expérience au musée je
partais au vietnam pour faire une
résidence à côté de la noyer dans un
petit village là où il y avait tous et
est intemporel celle de l'art partout il
ya pas beaucoup de musées ou de galeries
mais parce qu'il ya de l'art par toucher
les gens il ya plein de petits détails
de bois de charpente de calligraphie de
céramique et du coup là j'ai eu accès à
un studio de céramique à des grands
fours et on a fait nous mêmes notre
terre on a ramassé on a travaillé on a
passé lors d'une machine est donc ce qui
est super avec ce matériel c'est que ça
peut être tout à fait éphémère sa vie se
faire bien ou alors ça peut être mis les
nerfs des qui s'est passé dans un four
on peut retrouver des poteries
il ya très très longtemps et
voilà ça c'est d'époque sur lequel j'ai
travaillé des mots en vietnamien donc ce
qui avec l'écriture du fait de la mienne
c'est que c'est le seul pays ou en asie
qui en quoi qui où il emploie la lettre
par laquelle graphie latine
il met juste des accents dc10 en plus
donc c'est je me perdais pas trop par
rapport aux idéogrammes qu'on peut
trouver dans d'autres pays en asie
donc je pouvais composer et là c'est un
mur que j'ai fait vraiment avec de
l'argile à la base de mur il est en
argile en terre crue avec la paille est
hélas j'ai passé des couches et des
couches son écriture jusqu'à ce qu'elles
elles prennent un relief jusqu'à ce que
ça soit un bas relief et quand je
peignais ce j'entends des leçons de
l'eau de l'argile du mur même le lieu il
y avait beaucoup de résonance dans ce
musée
il ya des partis qui tombait et je
trouvais ça vraiment
ça c'est juste quoi par rapport à ce que
je veux ce que j'avais en tête et donc
je mettais de l'eau dessus et à des
teintes est toute différente qui qui
venaient se superposer après l'ena il y
avait le maroc
mon père a construit mon père était
architecte et construisez des maisons en
terre d'en-haut maghreb et après son
décès je suis allé au maroc pour les
disperser ses cendres dans le désert
c'est ce sens oui et entend marge et
écrit son nom en arabe ou blanc de
meudon un peu partout sur le chemin ça
va venir de faire un hommage est aussi
agile c'est bon pour la peau c'est comme
vous savez donc ça a plein de bienfaits
et donc au maroc dans la rivière je me
suis je me suis mis plein de vous avec
mon frère est donc ce qui est génial
aussi se faire par rapport à l'
architecture en terre c'est que les
villes dans lesquelles on vit elle ne
sont pas construites à échelle humaine
là au maroc c'est des architectes ces
architectures sans architecte c'est à
dire que le gars qui fait deux mètres de
haut et bas il va contre sa maison elle
sera aussi autre que lui et il ya
quelque chose qui est très très très
très très beau là dedans c'est vraiment
une continuité de la terre quoi est ce
un pays super bien avec le temps et si
c'est plus pour les hommes ce sera pour
les cigognes poules et les animaux qui
n'ont pas de toit
c'est un voyage récent j'étais chez des
potiers et ils m'ont offert plein plein
de pau qui était fêlée j'ai construit
une sorte de sculpture avec des pauvres
en équilibre qui n'a pu mat pas tenu
longtemps des enfants sont amusés à la
casse et mais c'est pas grave moi j'ai
j'ai vécu ce moment et ça m'a donné des
idées des idées pour pour y retourner
faire ça donc ça c'était des lettres les
personnages qui forme des lettres
donc là il est marqué parole et donc ça
c'est juste avec de l'argile de la terre
dugré et c'est assez solide quoi donc ça
j'ai même pas mis dans le j'ai même pas
mis dans le four est donc c'est aussi
par rapport aux graffitis dans dans la
rue des grands mouvements pour faire des
grandes lettres et je voulais
montrer aussi que le corps est une
architecture et qui a une danse aussi
dans la peinture est alors je vais
t'aider mais terminer par la ces dans la
forêt de soignes
c'est aussi en blanc de meudon j'ai fait
un petit jeu mot que j'ai marqué la
forêt de soignes
parce que c'est chaque fois de l'oxygène
et qu' il faut absolument que les joues
les choses soient durables ce qui est
beau c'est vraiment le détachement par
rapport à ce qui peut durer c'est à dire
que dans j'ai fait pas mal de murales
dans la ville il ya des gens qu'ils
aillent les botton mieux mais je me
disais c'est pas mon mur c'est à tout le
monde et tant mieux s'il y en a qui
passent par là et qui font des autres
dessins dessus c'est à dire qu'il faut
vraiment en tant qu'artiste va lâcher
des offres chez comme des petits bébés
et tout ça que j'y mets tout mon coeur
tout le monde a mais avec des histoires
et du sens et ensuite je m'en détache
d'importance et l'action c'est l'action
c'est qui est la beauté c'est l'acte est
donc voila merci à vous pour vos
oreilles
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]